what else you got Nick he's a beautiful
family right here
I know those real children they are and
this is a debate club more wholesome
LaVon Brendan Schaub hey we're just
sitting here in quarantine and faeo me
and my wife wouldn't want to walk down
the out of that Bishop gun hitter yeah
like my call on this past weekend but
we're just here with my new toy my new
baby boy we were having a debate so we
wanted to bay with you the new or the
old Lion King
Oh bro you tell us they probably watched
it 17 times like me and laws buzz poopy
diapers dang bro congratulations on a
nutfah that beautiful cut right there
this is Mark
oh that's so cool man love is dope tight
[Music]
that's a great thanks man yeah that's
awesome man and the rest of you won't
feel liking the newer the old dude the
new is some [ __ ] listen if I want it
real that National Geographic I want I
want my Disney [ __ ] man you know I'm
saying also Beyonce [ __ ] it up [ __ ] it
up dude yeah have you seen it a new
thing yeah it's weak you have to go on
these riffs and [ __ ] is weak man
was it the old ones way better Elton
John singing that [ __ ] like my own
it sounds like Kermit the Frog hold on
is this well you don't know [ __ ] man
remember I told you that earlier you
forgot I remember come on man you forgot
bro
definitely definitely an old Lion King
though that cartoons it gets hard to
replace things for people man if it's
younger people they watch the old when
it looks old to them so they only know
that it's it's funner you know I'm
saying like this new age ship that we're
doing like Batman I don't need the real
story of Batman
I don't need my Bruce Wayne being in the
real world I like that old [ __ ] Batman
Returns mr. freeze yeah everybody jus
come on do it come on kill me do it I
mean it's not like a Irish dude wrapped
in a bag bro come on do it
come on Timmy come on do it now kill me
that's pretty good I'm good right you
full of [ __ ]
you probably starving bro you like spelt
lightheaded Grossman give me yeah do you
got water in your lungs you out of your
damn mind right now man your little out
of you got waterboarded what abort
yourself bro yeah I don't like the
new-age [ __ ] the Batman's the
superheroes I don't like that [ __ ] you
have a look I struggle with a lot of the
remake stuff man you know I like a lot
of the originals but I haven't seen the
new king the the new uh lion Kings yeah
don't waste your time you're my son
halfway through what Papa I'm bored
really yeah cuz - it's too real yeah the
play I saw was good I went did go and
see the play I would that's like on my
bucket list it looks incredible the
Disney play it ruined Broadway but
because now it's all just Disney and
they sell merch through oh really
Broadway yeah like it Broadway is now
like movies it's only big blockbusters
like by Disney like wicked yeah I mean
that's like that's one that's kind of
stood the test of time but it's like
they just keep popping out these Disney
one's a little juice now are they that
sounds interesting but yes so big-budget
spider-man they did Loen they all go to
Broadway now wow they found that other
outlet mm-hmm yeah my friend Dodd Loomis
used to run uh do all the he was a
director or something I think of all the
yeah and so I went down and watched him
sometime and it's seeing the costumes
and everything that was amazing yeah how
talented there and then we get paid yeah
that's for the love of the gangs or
worse they paid worse than UFC fighters
yeah they're working their ass off eight
shows a week that's for the love of [ __ ]
uh game right there that's the play yeah
[ __ ] looks ridiculous and all the pieces
of the costume and how they put them all
together and they move at all it's
pretty magnificent it's art - so I'm
gonna go with that outside issue brother
play I was hoping someone would say that
thank you verified you knew that
information man you have information
that you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
nothing
[Music]